hey guys it's video with max tech and
welcome to our ultimate gaming review of
the m2 macbook air where i'm going to
use different methods to play different
games like using native games like world
of warcraft rosetta games like cs go and
i'm going to use crossover 21 from
codeweavers to play some windows only
games like grand theft auto 5 and the
witcher 3 to see if this macbook air can
give us some good fps and handle the
heat as well and not only that but i'm
going to be monitoring the gpu
frequencies and the wattage to see what
happens with any potential thermal
throttling by using this power metrics
app called acetop and before i get
started i do want to mention which
configuration of the m2 macbook air i
have i have the 16 gig ram model as well
as the 512 gig ssd so that way we're not
dealing with any of the single nand chip
issues and of course this model also has
the 10 core gpu upgrade because if
you're interested in gaming you're
likely going for that 10 core but just
as a little disclaimer i do want to
mention that this configuration is
pretty expensive it's 1700 and it won't
even ship until september whereas you
can go on amazon right now and get a
brand new 14-inch macbook pro which is
much better in so many different ways in
terms of the features and the
performance as well for only 17.50 so 50
bucks more compared to this model and of
course it has a fan for the gaming
performance and everything else but if
you're looking for a very portable
macbook like this m2 macbook air that's
what this video is for so let's see if
you can get some decent fps and gaming
experience with this machine all right
now getting right into it the first game
i'm gonna play is world of warcraft
because it's one of the only fully
native and optimized games for mac os at
least apple silicon right now and i do
have my power metrics asset top open
right here and keep in mind that i have
the temps right here that's showing the
gpu clusters so watch that as well and
let's get started alright so i'm in full
screen mode but i do want to go into the
system settings switch it to windowed
really quick and then i do want to set
my resolution to 2560 by 1600 and i do
need to turn the resolution scale up to
2560 to match 60 fps let's look at the
acid top it's using around let's see one
watt wow very efficient so far and it
looks like the gpu is not being maxed
out we're sitting at 68 usage so it's
not maxing out and that's because
my fps is limited to 60 right now so let
me actually move this over and keep in
mind i have my gpu right here so pay
attention to that number now the reason
i'm capped at 60 is because vertical
sync is on so i'm going to turn this off
it's going to allow the fps to go
wherever it wants to so it looks like 88
so it looks like at these recommended
settings it's actually doing quite well
you can see it's got it set to four so
they're turned down a little bit now i
want to see what happens if i turn up
the graphics settings
to 10. there you go all right look at
that 9.4 watts gpu it's definitely
turning up 10.5 watts gpu usage right
over there look at that that is really
high 10.6 10.62 100 gpu usage you can
see right at the top right there 10.58
and now our fps is actually down to
under 60 so 55
fps ish ooh look at that 10.77 it's
using more now 100 gpu usage this is
basically how a game should be reacting
and look ooh look at that 58 59 fps so
between let's say 56 to 60 fps 10.5
watts used oh and now the chip is
starting to heat up look at that 92
degrees celsius now that we're walking
around a bit we're using a little bit of
the cpu 21
temps are going down 89 degrees celsius
now look at that what's up with that
looks like the gpu is using less wattage
now 1400 is the max gpu usage you can
have back to 90 degrees celsius this is
actually impressive performance so far
we're sticking to around 60 fps and
that's at like
native resolution basically and fully
maxed out graphic settings i just forgot
i should be using my mouse temps are
heating up i just saw 97 degrees right
there so
heating up now it drops back down to oh
there you go 97 again 100 degrees we
just hit a hundred whoa right guys this
is very interesting i was at 100 degrees
now i'm going down 95 94 it's like
rapidly decreasing the clock speeds are
down under 1200 now they were at 1400
maxed out look at that 92 degrees oh
look at the wattage
the wattage is going down it's under 7
watts it was at 10.5 almost the temps
are rapidly decreasing 89 degrees
celsius now look at that it's limited
even though it says 100 gpu usage 99
right there the clock speeds themselves
are going down it's throttling itself
and look at that you can see the fps
drop as well we're sitting at 50 fps
5152 now so it seems like
as soon as it triggered at a certain
temperature it just started to slow down
almost like the chassis itself
is a heat soaking which is something
that luke miyani noticed when he used
his machine outside guys look at the
temps 84 degrees celsius oh the gpu is
at a thousand fifty it is throttling
six watts all right what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna keep playing it's been around
i don't know 10 to 15 minutes that i've
been playing so far and we're already
getting some significant throttling so
i'm gonna keep playing to see what it
kind of stabilizes at over time oh and
it looks like my resolution actually
wasn't
full because i just kind of double
clicked on this
screen and it went larger so it looks
like this is the proper
resolution and we're down to around oh
look at that 35 fps
it keeps dropping almost like it's
putting a bigger load now that we have
more resolution
and the temp is down to 81. it's like it
keeps dropping 4.8 4.3
gpu usage so all in all it looks like if
you wanted to get perfect 60fps at
native resolution you wouldn't be able
to play at the uh maxed out graphics
settings at first it was fine but then
when you start heat soaking the chassis
it just starts throttling down the clock
speeds throttling down the wattage
bringing down the chip temperature and
of course bringing down the fps which
now that we're in the full native res
it's now below 40. look at that 37 fps
so you'd likely have to
turn down the graphics quality to get a
solid 60 fps and you should probably
also turn on vertical sync
because that'll cap the frame rate and
it'll uh cap your gpu usage as well but
overall for a game like world of
warcraft it's actually pretty good as
long as you don't max out the settings
you can probably achieve a good solid
60fps and now let's move over to the
next game which is csgo which is running
on mac os under rosetta all right so
right now i'm going to try to switch to
full screen window 2560x1600
unfortunately i still don't see what i
have at the top like my temps menu bar
and let's see what happens if i get out
of it yep it looks like it does cut
the gpu power when you're not looking so
i'm gonna have to go back and look at
like the average usage over time we have
our settings set to auto with a bunch of
this stuff set to high shader detail
very high all right i don't know if you
can see that fps but right there we're
looking at a 91 71 45 so it kind of
fluctuates
ah okay 67 70 so that's pretty good fps
so far so i also wonder if we'll get
heat soaked over time
and we'll see how the fps reacts
49 right there 47.
so far it hasn't been the smoothest
experience i don't know like the fps is
still fine it's like above 40 a lot of
the time but there's some weird like
glitchiness and i don't know what that's
from i don't know if it's from like
rosetta or it's unoptimized
i'm not sure
[Music]
yo come on so close but i don't think
the system is heat soaking so i'm going
to try and see yep 75 degrees it was
running at low gpu usage
no it wasn't really that bad now with
that said csgo worked pretty well
without heat soaking the whole system so
it didn't really throttle much which is
very interesting and it was a decent
gaming experience it was a little bit
glitchy i don't know if it's from
rosetta or whatever else but you could
probably turn down your graphics
settings and get a decent gaming
experience with cs go and now let's move
on to another light game which is league
of legends running on mac os using
rosetta once again so let's see if this
m2 macbook air is just good enough to
run this alrighty we're in game i do
want to go over to the video and see if
i can switch it to uh windowed and i
could actually switch and see my gpu
wattage as well so i'm going to set it
to uh
2560 by 1664.
and let's max everything out since
league of legends is a pretty easy game
look at that fps
180 170 okay now that we're fighting a
hundred i mean like what more do you
want temps are still staying down
this is excellent oh i forgot to buy
stuff looking at our wattage oh it's
barely using any gpu wattage at all
like this game is cake even without the
frame rate capped to 60 gpu is barely
being used
i mean look at that 80 gpu usage 70
percent red
all right look at that 83
barely any gpu usage like i don't know
it's
crazy so it looks like
if your game isn't using 100 of this gpu
it's not to heat up i mean 73 degrees
celsius no issues with fps no issues
with nothing right now i forgot to buy
stuff again all right well that settles
it over 100 fps fully maxed out we got
native resolution basically so
no issues temps
basically no issues they're slowly
climbing 71.72
but still
i think it's fine but now let's jump
into something a little bit more
difficult which is playing windows based
games like grand theft auto 5 and
witcher 3 using crossover 21 now if you
don't know what this app is it basically
translate the windows based apis into
apis that mac os
can read and play and as far as i know
this is the most reliable way to play
windows games on mac os right now
because bootcamp is no longer available
so you get a 14 day free trial but if
you do want to purchase the full version
you can use the coupon code max tech 25
for 25 off your first purchase so
definitely do that you can find the
links down below so before i get into
grand theft auto 5 let's do the witcher
3 first and here we are in the settings
i've set the frames per second to
unlimited vsync is off i set it to
windowed mode to a lot lower resolution
this is 1470 by 918 because this does
take extra processing as you can see
just as processing taking up to 45 of
the cpu now down to 40 percent so it
kind of goes in waves so we'll see how
it reacts in terms of temps while
playing it at these lower resolution
settings so far already i just started
i'm looking at like 90 degrees celsius
92 it's heating up fairly quickly
because it's using oh my goodness 100 of
the gpu and a good amount of the cpu as
well 102 degrees now so it's definitely
heating up opening this up it looks like
it's already throttling looks like we're
under 1200
gpu clock speed around under 6 watts as
well
so it's already throttling down
the gpu because you can see average was
just at 7 watts peak at 8.83 and just
like that first time it is throttling
down the temps are going down to 85
degrees right now looking at the
terminal oh my goodness look at that the
gpu is down like crazy 690 700 under 3
watts right now it is seriously
throttling it because of course this is
using crossover which also has the
translation going on using up what 45
percent of the cpu and 100 gpu this is
where you're gonna see major throttling
i could definitely tell that the fps is
not 60 it's not smooth unfortunately i
don't see
how much it is right now but looking at
these clock speeds under 700 megahertz
that's basically
two times throttling from the 1400
that it should run at at full load and
look at that the gpu is under 3 watts
it's basically running in like low power
mode right now and of course the temps
are down to 77 degrees celsius because i
don't know it just heat soaked and it
throttled it's not letting it get
more power to it to heat it up more and
i am getting some glitchiness as well
nowhere near 60 fps so it looks like the
gpu is kind of stabilizing now around
750 megahertz and right under 3 watts
cools oh my goodness what is going on
now that we're fighting people this is
not a good experience it's kind of like
glitchy uh the fps is not good oh my
goodness you guys seen this this is not
smooth this machine feels pretty hot
actually you know what i'm gonna grab my
thermal camera look at that 45 46
degrees celsius right there in the
center
this thing is heat soaked this is crazy
that is very interesting because the
temps on the gpu clusters are only 77
degrees celsius so even though it slowed
down the clock speeds and the temps as
you can see look at that 750 megahertz
that's almost two times throttling the
gpu down a 3.3 watts even though it
throttled the actual chassis is still
really hot 46 degrees celsius nowhere
near a solid smooth 60 but at least it's
playable right now
in this case it's still playable but the
chassis is hot so what this tells us is
that if you're gonna be doing some
gaming like crossover something that's
more serious and not kind of a lighter
load like those other games i played
you're definitely gonna want the m2
macbook pro so you can at least not have
up to two times throttling
on this m2 macbook air and final update
you can see basically 700 megahertz
three watts on the gpu like remember we
used to get up to 10.5 watts as soon as
we turned on world of warcraft that's
around how much you should be running at
full load on your gpu but look how much
it throttles this is just insane so it
just sucks to see that
if you didn't have the throttling the
fps would have been much better
in this case but it's not and now let's
move on to playing some grand theft auto
5 that was definitely fun playing the
witcher 3 once again crossover 21 is
basically the only way that you can do
that playing windows games on mac os so
use that code max tech 25 if you want to
buy crossover so here we are in grand
theft auto 5 playing through the very
beginning which is a little bit annoying
but
so far it looks like the gpu is not
going up to 100 usage it's sitting at 89
while the cpu is being used quite a bit
55
but the temps are not going up as i can
tell right now let's
look at the terminal looks like the gpu
usage is very low at least when i had it
open so the temps are not
reaching very high so far so the temps
are now starting to heat up a little bit
80 to 83 degrees celsius but nowhere
near as much as it had in a witcher 3
because i think the gpu still is not
using 100 for some reason which
could actually be really good experience
is definitely not perfect though i don't
know if this is from rosetta and now
even in this section it looks like it's
able to handle the game without going up
to 100 gpu usage which is not allowing
it to heat up that fast which is
interesting so i do want to take a look
at the oh it does look like the gpu was
not being used at maximo is only using
about 1.3 watts surprisingly so it might
have actually been throttling already so
it seems like although gta 5 isn't
running perfectly it's still running
decently well probably not perfect 60
fps with the little glitches but it is
not thermal throttling and heating up
like the other game witcher 3 did so
definitely not bad all right now with
all those games out of the way i'm
honestly pretty impressed because it
handled world of warcraft pretty well it
did throttle down the clock speeds but
it didn't lose that much in terms of fps
because the new gpu cores are pretty
efficient so they do a decent job now
league of legends and cs go those games
were fine especially league of legends
no issues at all so if it's any light
game like that the m2 macbook air should
be able to handle it now when we started
playing witcher 3 that is when we
started seeing some significant thermal
throttling with the clock speeds going
down basically getting cut in half so if
you're doing any kind of like extreme
aaa games especially stuff with
crossover you do not want to be on this
m2 macbook air especially since this
model right here has 16 gigs of ram five
12 gig ssd which is basically minimum if
you're going to be doing gaming and it
has the 10 core gpu for 1700
so i'd recommend just paying the extra
50 bucks getting the 14 inch because
you're gonna have the fan there's gonna
be no issues i would not recommend going
with the base m2 macbook pro even with
the fan because you're getting the old
design you don't want to deal with that
but with all that said here's my
conclusion if you're doing light gaming
like league of legends and other stuff
that's optimized well then this thing
should be fine you might experience a
little bit of throttling but what you
could do is you can cap the fps at 60
turn down the settings you'll probably
be fine with this m2 macbook air but i
still recommend going for the 14 inch
because it's only 50 bucks more than
this model so hopefully you guys enjoy
this gaming review and if you did go
ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe help us reach a million subs
before the end of the month thanks for
watching guys and definitely check out
those two videos we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]